The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aihi
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
Um, so Mr. Golding, I wanted to ask you,
we were going back and forth on the
emails and uh you were proposing a
sparring match. Uh, you said you you
spoke to your legal adviserss and they
were saying that u this is not going to
be something that we can license. Uh, I
want you to explain to the public
exactly what you've um what you've
spoken to them about and uh the details
pertaining to that.
So, it was yourself that tried to get us
on a a mainstream or localized
regionalized MMA event. And of course,
that's too problematical because you're
controversial, I'm controversial. If my
fans turn up and your fans turn up, no
one wants to touch that. It's it's too
extreme and too controversial. Uh so
then we went for the idea of having what
you said an underground event. Uh and
obviously I put that to my solicitors.
I've put it to a criminal solicitor,
civil solicitor, they both come back
with the same thing. It's a little bit
problematical because the reason we have
a license in infrastructure in this
country regarding fights is because
essentially it suspends the law. So if
me and you jump in a ring and it's
licensed, we can batter away at each
other, no problems. But if it's
unlicensed, you could get done for ABH
or common assault and so could I. So,
what has been proposed to me by my legal
advisors is to have a sparring session.
>> Sure.
>> And let the let the ether live stream
it, put the video up afterwards and let
the public decide.
>> And in that sparring session, like how
would it um how would it be? So, what
what kind of gloves would you want me to
wear? What kind of gloves would you
wear? Uh would you want to put on a
head, you know, protective head gear?
What would you want to do exactly? Uh
who would be the referee? Do you have
any answers to these particular
questions or
>> referees can be hired, so can medical
staff. We can make sure all of that's
available. It will be in a controlled,
as far as the laws concerned, a
controlled sports environment. So, it'
still be exactly the same in every
single way. Uh except that it would be a
sparring session as opposed to a full
contest, a full bout at an event. Uh and
that way we can get this done. You want
you want this to happen. I want this to
happen. We've been emailing backwards
and forwards now for a few months. Uh
I've been waiting patiently for your
fight to happen recently. Uh and there's
there's nothing going to stop this
happening. Even if me and you both have
to hop on a plane to China, this is
going ahead one way or another. Uh
you've got a preference for I suggested
we go to Spain do it. You've got a
preference for doing it in the UK. This
looks like the only way we are actually
going to be able to actually do this and
put this on and make it happen. Uh, so
yeah, let's let's agree a date. MMA
rules.
>> Sure. What about the um the gloves and
all that stuff? Um,
>> 4 oz MMA gloves.
>> Sorry. 4 oz. Yeah.
>> Just like you was fighting in recently.
4 oz MMA gloves and we'll jump in there.
Three five minute rounds, three three
minute rounds, whatever's you can decide
all of that. Um, but the point I think
you want me to make tonight is that to
publicly commit to make this happen and
I I'm absolutely determined as are you
to make this happen one way or another.
And I know it doesn't mean much to you,
but if you want, I've got me Bible here,
and I I swear on the Bible that this is
going to happen one way or another.
>> All right. How's your How's your
granddad's health anyway? How how's he
doing? Very very good. Thank you.
>> Yeah, he's a Muslim doctor, wasn't he?
The the one who's treating him.
>> Was a Muslim's doctor's name on the
wall.
>> Is he a good guy? Is he Is it Do you
want him back uh sent back to Pakistan
or wherever he's from?
>> Absolutely, 100%. Because if it wasn't
Musl if it wasn't Muslim doctors in
these hospitals, then it' be English
doctors. So, I don't see the problem
here. our country as you know my
position is that we're having wave after
wave of unwanted uninvited mass
immigration into this country and I
would send every last one back
>> that's are they are they doing something
good these Muslim doctors in the NHS do
you think or is that good contribution
or is it a negative contribution
>> of course it's a good cont contribution
but the point is I'm not it's not a
matter of attacking people individually
which is what you're trying to you're
trying to bring this down to a personal
level to make it seem like I'm being
mean to someone who's helping a family
member. The point is this is a tiny
overcrowded island with barely enough
space and resources for own people. And
if this was happening in reverse in
Pakistan or wherever you're from, Egypt,
wherever your parents or grandparents
are from, then they wouldn't put up with
this wave after wave, millions of white.
>> It did. It did happen reverse. It was
called colonialism. Um,
>> yeah.
>> And would you say that colonialism was
bad?
>> Yeah. The kind of colonialism that we
saw in in Pakistan, India, and Egypt, I
think was bad. Um, but the point I'm
making is that like in most of you guys'
content, the far right. See, you've been
a little bit more fair here today. You
were saying that,
>> you know, they're doing a good job, you
know, the doctors are doing a good job,
but that a lot of you guys' content
doesn't recognize any of the positive
contributions of uh say immigrants or
children of immigrants or Muslims in
particular. So, are you willing to
concede that there there is a good
contribution here that Muslims are
doing?
>> There's a good contribution. There's
lots of negative contributions as well
because as you know not every single
Muslim in the whole in the United
Kingdom is a is Dr. Muhammad from a
hospital in London. You know there
there's there's good and bad but the
point is on a government policy level
this country is being swamped by mass
immigration. We're on track to be a
minority in our own country. You tell me
what indigenous people around the world
>> I don't think you're on track to be a
minority in your own country. I don't
think any projections show that. Like I
was looking at some of the stats. The
Pew have done like um a research on the
matter and they they've given like a
conservative estimate of how there's a
6% Muslim population in in the UK and
they've looked at for example 2050 or
2000 if there's high immigration what
the country will look like and if
there's low immigration and it doesn't
exceed 20% in any situation. Um
>> that's nonsense. the the ethnic minority
population or immigrant origin
population of the United Kingdom as we
speak is 25% we're with the native
British people 75%. And that is uh the
ratios are dro for us native British
people from 75% were dropping rapidly.
Mass immigration last year we had 1.2
million foreigners come into the country
to settle. That's a city the size of
Glasgow. And if you fast forward the
tape 20 years, that's 20 cities the size
of Glasgow purely of third world
immigrants just being dotted on a map of
Britain. But the point is,
>> last time I saw the You're kind of
right, but I mean in terms of the
percentage of the indigenous, but last
time I saw the Office of National
Statistic um statistics on it, they said
there was an 83% white population in
Britain and a 17% ethnic uh population.
Um, as I say, that's not really atypical
of any any country. Like for you have
Muslim countries, Malaysia for example,
Bosnia another example, you have Muslim
countries with significant non-Muslim uh
populations. Um so it's why is this such
a big issue for someone like yourself
where you you feel I understand the
point about like you know uncontrolled
immigration but why is it a sticking
point that you know it's anti-Muslim
sentiment and this kind of anti- I would
say ethnic sentiment as well like why is
it that because my family are born and b
south London and they had to move out of
South London because of mass immigration
back in the ' 70s and so on. Um, I've
watched my own town of Arif in Southeast
London completely transformed by mass
immigration. We're now a minority in
London. We're a minority in Leicester, a
minority in Birmingham, uh, and so many
other towns and cities. And if you just
fast forward the tape, we're being we're
being reduced and reduced eventually. We
can argue about the the numbers and the
years this will take place, when we'll
arrive at that destination, but this is
where we are heading. And I'm sorry, I'm
against that and I've always been
against it. As I say, as I say like in
the beginning when I said to you that u
pure research done a research on if not
just in the UK but entire entirety of
Europe if immigration continued in a
certain trajectory that um it wouldn't
be the numbers that you're talking
about. It's just completely incorrect.
Um you're you're saying that was wrong
but you haven't cited any particular
sources. Uh so if you were to site a
source for what you're saying I would
appreciate that. Well, with all due
respect, you invited me on here to talk
briefly about our upcoming fight. So,
I'm not armed with sources and figures
and statistics.
>> Well, this is your area of expertise,
isn't it? I mean, you're a far right,
you know, nationalist or I don't know
how you patriot.
>> Yeah, but you have to admit this is a
bit of an ambush. You're saying, please
site some sources and show me some
statistics. You invited me on here and
you're you're smiling now. You invited
me on here to briefly discuss. You think
this is an ambush? I don't know why you
think you're already pressured. We're
not We're not engaging in any physical
altercation and we're just talking very
gently towards each other and speaking.
I'm listening to what you're saying. You
listen to what I'm saying. You're
describing this as an ambush and and you
want us to believe that you're going to
fight with me in in an environment. I
mean, so this is if this is something
threatening to you, I I don't see how
you're going to, you know, come to a
fight.
>> No one said I felt threatened. What I'm
saying is we're supposed to be
discussing our upcoming fight. You've
we've discussed the particulars of that
and we
>> we've discussed it and we've got nothing
left to say. Then I'll get on with my
evening because you invited me on here
to discuss our fight. If you want, we
can schedule a debate or a discussion
and I'll having one. I don't know why
we're having a discussion now. If you're
going to run away from this, then people
are going to say, "Well, this guy is
wanting us all to believe that he's
going to be a pay-per-view live event
and he's finding it hard to continue a
normal conversation with the guy. You
want us all to believe that we're going
to pay people are going to pay
pay-per-view. People are going to pay
money to to see this event. And so if if
we are not convinced that you know that
you're going to be able to show up, I
mean, you're just having a conversation.
You're feeling very very nervous and
threatened.
>> I'm not feeling nervous and I'm not
feeling
>> Why you trying to run away?
>> I don't know. Understand? We're just
talking because because I we was
emailing each other what 20 minutes ago
and I said, "Look,
>> I'll give you five minutes to talk about
the fight. That's it. And now you're
digressing on to immigration, Islam,
demographics. So, let's just get back to
what we was talking about. You invited
me on here to talk about our fight. I
swear.
>> So, you said you want to do a sparring
match and you said you want me to wear 4
oz gloves with no protective gear. So,
no shin pads and no head gear. I said
that's fine. I that's no problem at all.
We can we can arrange.
>> Well, then let's agree a date. What was
the date I sent you the other day?
>> Um, I don't know, but we can we can sort
that out. I'd have to look at my
schedule for the date because uh I've
got pretty packed schedule. I'm
finishing off the PhD uh actually. Um so
I need to um yeah got some examinations
on that first. So uh yeah, no problem.
We can agree with that on on the emails.
That's not a problem. But when I would
suggest on this point actually that we
don't last time you kind of jumped the
gun a little bit making I I think you
made some promotional content um like a
video or something like that or some
something.
>> Yeah, sure. Sure. I I enjoyed I enjoyed
it myself and you had like grudge match
and my face and your I would say I would
suggest unless we both agree on the date
and the place place and time uh that we
shouldn't we shouldn't uh you know
announce it or tell the public if that's
agreeable to you.
>> Yeah. And we'll work this out via email
and then by mutual consent we'll we'll
create a poster or a video promote the
the the event and then we'll put it out
there by mutual consent.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I'm mutual concern and um
what it is is is I'm going to give you
like the name of the location, whatever
it's going to be, some gym somewhere in
uh in the UK. If you're happy with that
particular gym, if you want another gym,
whatever you feel comfortable with. I
mean, if you have a suggestion for a
gym, I don't mind uh that as well. It
can be any anywhere you want. Um so
that's I think we've fleshed out all the
details here. Uh but I've got a couple
of things I've got to I've got a travel
very packed travel schedule and also
I've got my PhD examinations that I've
got to uh to do very important ones. But
just wanted to ask you a couple of
questions just before you leave and I'm
I'm sure you're not going to want to run
away because it's it's going to be a
really bad look if you do. So look,
we've spoken about a bit the demography.
Um you are fair enough in the beginning.
>> Look, with all due respect,
>> Mamemed sure I came on here to speak
about the event. We have I mean this
we're if you want if you want we can
rearrange and we can schedule a debate.
No problem.
>> But tonight
>> that's just we're just talking right. I
mean all we're doing right now is you've
got your your views right and you're on
Twitter every single day and you're
promulgating those views. I'm I've got
my views and I'm saying that you're
already a spokesperson for the far right
or for the for the nationalists or for
the patriots or whatever. So you clearly
have the information at hand. Otherwise,
you wouldn't see it fit to go on Twitter
and speak about things. So, all I'm just
saying to you right now is in terms of
the what you've mentioned before about
the numbers, the numbers are not in the
way that you're saying that they are.
Look,
>> well, if if you feel that way, let's
schedule a debate and I'll have all the
figures and stats available and we can
debate for hours if you want, but like I
said, via email, which you agree to
tonight, 5 10 minutes, we'll talk about
the fight
>> and we'll talk about the fight only. So
what you were saying in the beginning
then is the what you were saying in the
beginning with confidence you want to do
you want to retract those statements
because you're saying you're suggesting
now that you don't know the stats you
don't know the the sources so
>> no of course I know the stats I just
you're asking me for written sources uh
>> well not written sources just give me
any source that we can we can fact check
the internet can fact check you were
speaking confidently and stridently in
the beginning right and you were saying
this these are the numbers and this is
you were falsifying what I was saying
you were contradicting what I was saying
all it takes is for people to go and
Google these things and they'll find,
you know, exactly where I got my
information from. It's it's not it's not
a secret. I I saw it in GB News recently
because Nigel Farage was asked about it
by one of the GB News presenters. Are
you concerned that the British
population has plummeted to 74% of the
population? It's going down rapidly and
Nigel Farage replied, "No, that is not a
concern of mine." So it's
>> that's not that's not a credible source.
And the the fact is the fact is UB News
is not an academic source. But the fact
is it's 83% of white people. But then
would you consider black people to be
Brit British because they're not
including that in that 83%. So do you
think a black man is British or no?
>> I'll ask I'll answer it this way. Yeah.
Where are your parents from?
>> Uh Egypt.
>> Egypt. So in my mind you're an Egyptian.
>> I'm not Chinese. I'm not Japanese.
>> I'm not offended by that. I'm just
asking you. Would you think a black
person
>> and why should people who why should
people who come from Africa or the
Caribbean be offended when I say that
they're not British?
>> Well, that I'm asking you that if they
were born in this country, right? So, if
these people were born just like you are
in this country cuz surely like maybe
four or five generations down, somebody
came from another country, maybe
Ireland, maybe Scotland, maybe Wales,
maybe some of Wellington was the Duke of
Wellington was born in Ireland. Doesn't
make him Irish. He's he's a typical
English aristocrat. Joanna Joanna Lumley
the actress was born in India. No one no
one claims that Joanna Lumley is is
Indian. It doesn't matter. At
>> what point do we say no that's it's
interesting. I'm I'm trying to get I'm
just as the point here. At what point do
you say that someone is British? So how
many generations does it have to be?
>> So for example like if someone is mixed
race if someone's half black half white
for example and their you know their
great-grandparents are are black or
white would you consider them to be
British or where's the line? Yes, of
course. Like uh Father Calvin Robertson,
he's he's he's half Caribbean, half
English.
>> So you consider him to So So then the
question is where's the point? Because
he's black. I mean, he's half black.
>> At what point does someone become or not
become Pakistani? You know, you're
asking me You're asking me Darth
questions. You You're almost
>> I'm asking you. I can answer that
question for you. But you're almost
you're almost sounding like one of these
one of these leftwing uh highly biased,
you know, media hacks saying trying to
get right down into the nitty-gritty of
who's British and who's not.
>> No, but there needs to be like, you
know, there needs to be a measure here
because what I'm trying to get from you
is if you ask me what Pakistani is, you
can just simply say someone who was born
in Pakistan.
>> No, it's not someone who's born in
Pakistan. It's someone who for
generations is part of that nation. And
in
>> Well, it depends on how citizenship is
defined. I'm asking you about how
citizenship is defined.
>> The thing is right, all right, let's
let's rewind. I I've when you're talking
about this, if we were in government
tomorrow, you you have to look at this
from two perspectives. One is civic and
one is ancestral.
>> Sure.
>> Okay.
>> So, in a civic sense, people who are
born here,
>> even you know, pe people first
generation who are born here do become
British citizens.
>> And you accept that they're British?
>> No, I accept that they're British
citizens. But then in an ancestral
nationalistic
way of looking at things
>> then people who
>> in a one generation or two
>> originate overseas then no they're not
you can't look I
>> I get what you look I get what you're
saying there's there's this distinction
people are making now between British
and English as well like uh people
calling Anthony Joshua English and some
people object to that fact like in in
France for example they they call a
black man French there is no English
British distinction
And I I appreciate that there is some
scope for saying for example that your
kind of indigenal
or lineage based or biological kind of
race it does matter. Um but the question
I'm asking you is a little bit more
>> then we're on the same page with this
thing then.
>> No no I mean it does matter. I'm not not
suggesting that it doesn't. Like for
example many black people would consider
to with themselves to be black and
Caribbean at the same time. They would
>> and I totally respect that and I totally
understand that if I was in their
position I would feel I I would think
that as well.
>> So do you want these people out of the
country for example or do or is that a
misconception?
>> What we want to do is to reverse the
situation. So we've had immigration
>> and we want remigration. So we would
first of all we would deport anyone
connected to Islamic extremism. And I'm
sorry in my view you would be on the
first plane being honest.
>> No problem. And
>> yeah, you'd be you you'd be deported
with within a heartbeat to be fair. No
problem.
>> Um, so Islamic extremists would be
deported, illegal immigrants would be
deported. Uh, and we just roll back the
tape. People who are foreign criminals,
for example, and we just roll back the
tape until the British people become 90%
of the population. That is our official
policy. So in terms of like you you've
said that you respect that if if you've
got a black person who's half Jamaican
oh sorry who's who's Jamaican whose
parents are from Jamaica for example or
whose grandparents have come from um
Jamaica that you you respect the fact
that they can identify both as Jamaican
in a sense because they respect where
they come from but at the same time as
British in a sense because they they
were born here and they only understand
the English language they only
understand British culture. So you you
appreciate that fact that there's a dual
kind of identification thing. I think
it's entirely natural you to use your
example. I think it's entirely natural
if
>> you've got an average black man in
London, a black lad um in his 20ies for
example, and his parents were from the
Caribbean. Uh but he was born here and
he this is all he knows. I could
understand that he's got a level of
attachment to this country. Um but
>> you would you said you would you would
identify if you were in his case, you
would identify as both British and
Jamaican. You would you accept that for
him, right? Well, I don't I don't think
you can. I can't see. I see this in the
media all the time. You know, British
Indian, British Pakistani. You look,
there's no such thing. You can't be
there.
>> No such thing, though.
>> You can't be Anglo Anglo-Saxon
Pakistani. You can't be an Anglo-Saxon
Mongolian. Come on.
>> Why is it So, okay, let me ask you this.
Is it in your view? Is it only
biological? Then is the only marker
biological marker?
>> It's ancestral. Yes. So, look, my my
parents look I'll give you an example.
My parents are British. Y
>> and my grandparents are British. And if
you you did this over and over again,
we'd go all the way back to Stonehenge.
>> No, but this is a circular argument
because we're talking about what is it
to be British. So you can't say, well,
we're British. I'm saying that at what
point do you become British? So what I'm
trying to say to you is if you're, let's
say, for example, half black and half
white. The question is at that point in
your view, would you would you be
British or not be British? How much
white do you have to be to be British is
the question. It's not, look, it's not a
matter of being white because if a
Polish person
>> is you,
>> Hold on, let me speak. Okay, let me
speak. If a Polish person came over
here, okay, then they would still remain
Polish, they wouldn't be all of a sudden
become English like and they're white.
So, it's not a m It's a matter of common
sense really. Look, I'm not a Pakistani
and it doesn't matter if I was born in
Islamabad or my children were born in
Islam. We're not going to be Pakistani,
okay? We'll just be English immigrants
in Pakistan. Do you agree with that?
Uh say that again. So say say it one
more time.
>> Okay. So if I moved to Pakistan and had
children in Pakistan in Islamabad
>> if they were born in Islamabad
>> if they were born in Islamabad. Okay.
But you know they wouldn't be Pakistani
and they wouldn't be viewed as Pakistani
by the people.
>> Okay. So here's how I see it. Right. You
you have spoken up and I've seen that on
your Twitter feed. You've spoken up
about South Africans rights, minority
rights in South white South Africans.
Correct. you and Elon Musk and many
other people, right? So they do you
consider them to be South Africans or do
you consider them to be Europeans in
Africa?
>> I consider them to be Europe European
settlers that have moved from Europe to
South African in the British Empire.
>> So if they want to selfidentify as South
Africans, you say that's an illegitimate
selfidentification.
>> See this is this has got many
>> You agree with the blacks on this? You
agree with
>> this is like this has got many echoes
with like the trans debate. You know, if
I identified as a woman, it wouldn't
make me a woman, quite frankly. And
>> no problem. I just want to see. So, you
agree with the blacks in South Africa?
You agree with the Nelson Mandela's
party on this fact that these guys are
not uh actually uh the indigenous and
therefore they should the the farright
kind of black parties in South Africa?
You agree with them?
>> Fine. Yeah. Okay. I'll go with that. But
I tell you what, we'll take we'll give
South Africa, all the ethnic minority
population or the black population,
African population in Britain and we'll
exchange them for the Dutch and British
ancestral.
>> What about the white people in South
Africa that dis disregard and disagree
with what you're saying and they're
saying that we have be even though we
are white and we're South African, we
consider ourselves to be South Africa.
Are you going to are you saying that
your view uh should trump their view
that your essentially your will as a
white man in Britain should trump their
view as white people in South Africa?
>> Okay. Sooner or later there's a thing
called reality and that that applies to
us all. Okay. Men can't be women.
Pakistanis can't be English. White
European settlers can't be South
African. Okay. It's common sense. I feel
like
>> No, no. I I know what you're saying. I'm
sure you appreciate right
>> we're trying to get to the point where
we're trying to see what where's the
line because as you like for example in
America right you do you line the line
>> let me ask you this let me let me ask
you this cuz I I'm trying to get this in
America black people in America who who
only consider themselves to be
African-American are you saying they
should go back to West Africa
>> America is a a very different situation
because you've got essentially is a
country of immigrants but but Britain is
not a country of immigrants.
>> That's not true, is it? It's just it's
just when they migrated.
>> Well, you you you're clever enough to
know there's Anglo-Saxons that came into
Britain and all that kind of thing.
You're clever enough to know that
>> that there was it wasn't always there
were people from Ireland, there people
from from Wales that came in, people
different parts of Europe that came into
Britain that different white people that
basically make up. If you do, if you do
a DNA test right now, I'm pretty sure
you're going to have maybe part Irish,
part, you know, maybe Scottish, maybe
part, you know, German. It could be any
of that. Have you done a DNA test
before?
>> I haven't. No. Uh, but what you're
saying is completely academic. So, I'm
sure you agree that Nigeria, use Black
Africa, for example. There's no such
thing as a Nigerian race or a Congo race
or a Somali race. race is above the
nation state as you know and all white
Europeans share a common ancestry if you
go back far enough into prehistory but
that that race if you want to call it
that e ethnic group settled down and
broke up into languages and nations and
became nation states. So you're saying
Welsh people
>> you said African-Americans it's a
different situation but you didn't
explain why why so are these real
Americans or they're not Americans
>> are they real Americans or not? No,
because America is a country that's
founded by uh either black slaves and
white European settlers. So, it's not
the same situation you have with say
Germany or France.
>> Black slaves weren't weren't founding
the they were not in control of the
Constitution of America, the Declaration
of Independence. Uh they were brought
over from West Africa in a slave trade.
It was a different situation. They
weren't founding it in that sense, in
the governmental sense. So you could
essentially make the same argument that
you're making here about the black
Africans going back to West Africa. But
you seem to have a different standard
for America than you do for Britain
without proper justification. But what
what's your justification for that?
>> If you go back a thousand years, there
was no such thing as an indigenous
American people. Um
>> well, there was no such thing as a
British.
>> America's 200 250 years old or so. If
you go back a thousand years, what it
means to be a white Britain was
completely different in language and in
>> not white English. No, if you go back a
thousand years, you could be quite
easily white English.
>> Britain Britain is a
>> Hold on. When did Britain conquer 1066,
right?
>> 1066. Yes. The population of Britain was
over 2 million and 8,000 Norman knights
came over.
>> Sure. So these Normans, that was about a
thousand years ago and they came from
what is now France. Correct. But they
were Vikings. They settled in northern
France. Nor
>> you have Vikings and you had French and
you had people that are now what is is
German
years ago. You had all these immigrants
coming in and they they made you
basically
>> there's they weren't immigrants. Um
>> they didn't get on a plane and come over
and apply for a visa. Uh what you had
was
>> immigrated. Linguistically an immigrant
is someone who goes from one place to
another, isn't it? what what you had was
a a huge ethnic group which you can call
the white race eur white Europeans
whatever and eventually it broke up into
different languages different nation
states and so on those nation states
most of them like France and England for
example have been monolithic now for
over a thousand years
>> I'm I'm asking you that you said a
thousand years ago England wasn't the
same place but you're you're aware of
Hastings uh you're aware that it was in
1066 and you're aware that the
demography changed in England very
dramatically after that time. So,
>> no, that's incorrect. No, I'm I will
>> What do you mean
well known?
>> Hold on. According to the DNA studies,
when the Anglo-Saxons came over, they
changed the population to the degree of
20% of the population. When the
>> more than what you're talking about with
the Muslim population, 6%.
>> You're talking about white Europeans
coming into a country that was already
white European Polish come in. Then, 20%
Polish can come in. No, because no
because I would I would prefer that we
stopped all
>> what you prefer is irrelevant to the
look because the thing is the standard
here that you're using is so arbitrary
and so offkey and it keeps changing
depending on context without any
thought. So
>> every situation is going to change with
context. That's just nor you can't apply
what you know the same thing to to one
situation and then apply it to another
situation. Why not? That's called every
every country in the world came about
via a different route. Um via
>> you were consistent with the South
Africa thing which I have to commend you
for. Right. I mean to be fair you bit
the bullet with that. But then when we
went to America with the
African-Americans you applied
inconsistence and then said cited a
historical reason but then you said a
thousand years ago Britain wasn't the
same which is historically incorrect
because there was major demographic and
linguistic changes in British culture.
So you don't seem to get the history
right with this things. We need to we
need to know when when is it when is it
do you think is it acceptable for
immigrants to because a thousand years
ago the whole world was a different
place. I mean people were completely
different I mean in different countries.
So at what point do you say that okay
this is acceptable for these people to
be called indigenous to this particular
land at this particular time.
>> All I know is that my country is being
overrun with mass immigration primarily
from the third world primarily Islamic
and uh
>> you're going into a talking point. It's
changing. It's changing the face and the
nature and the future of my country. And
I'm sorry it I've dedicated my life to
reversing it. And you know, we can go
around in circle. You want to argue
about the minutiae and the the
nitty-gritty and the trivialities of
nationhood.
>> At the end of the day, we're British.
We're I'm English. And we want our
country back. And we want to preserve
not only the culture and the traditions
and the custom.
>> I I understand your desire.
>> I understand your desire to want to
You're a Christian man. you want some,
you know, Christianity is now a minority
religion because your people are not no
longer satisfied with that
intellectually or spiritually. Um,
>> well, but you could, I could also say
the same of Saudi Arabia and all these
other places which become very very
western very very quickly.
>> Oh, it's become western, but they still
maintain a Muslim identity. I the vast
overall
>> Yeah. But for how long? They might be a
couple of decades behind.
>> Well, actually, it's growing. It's
according to Pew again is Muslims will
be the majority in 2011. But
>> that's a good thing. That's a good
thing. Look, I would I I would support
Saudi Arabian nationalists keeping Saudi
Arabia a Muslim country. I would find
solidarity and kindred thinking with
those people 100%. I' I'd have more more
in hold, let me make this point. I had
more in common with with people like
that in Saudi Arabia who wanted to
preserve their country the way it's
historically been than I would with
white leftist politicians in Britain who
I who I truly hate and despise. You you
you would say that you would probably
try and paint me somehow as a racist and
a hater and all this. The only people I
truly hate is the traitors at
Westminster and the traitors the
journalists in the media. They're the
only people I truly hate.
>> Yeah. Well, Paul, I think what you
you're starting to mature in your
thinking now. I think this conversation
has
>> this has been my thinking for
>> dec
when you when I've given you those
thought experiments and and those
comparisons. I think now you're starting
to realize that the situation is a lot
more fluid than you think it is because
frankly, like I said, if you've got
someone who's 75% white and 25% black,
at what point do we say that this person
is indigenous to the land? Like you you
you accepted that Calvin, whatever his
name is, I don't know his name, Father
Calvin Robertson. Yeah.
>> Yeah. He's half black, half white. So he
doesn't even go over 50%. And you
accepted him as British. So you clearly
understand that it's not necessarily to
do with the color of your skin. Um and
but you don't have a formalized
philosophy as to exactly where and uh
where British hood starts and where it
ends. You don't have a formalized
philosophy on that. That's the problem
with the movement because you don't
>> that's your opinion. I would say it's
pretty crystal clear what we stand for.
We want to keep
>> we've already discussed that like you
know there's common sense. We want to
keep this country British and it's as
simple as that.
>> You want to keep it Are you saying you
want to keep it white?
>> Well, would you deny that the historic
British people have been a white
European people?
>> No, I'm asking you. Would you I'm asking
you the question. I mean, do you want to
keep it white?
>> Like I said, our policy generally
speaking because it is a like you say,
it's a nuanced complex situation that's
been inflicted on Britain without our
consent.
>> No, but you're you're you're evading the
question now, Paul. You're a brave man.
You're going to step in the ring. Come
on. You're a brave man. Come on. Tell me
now. Do you want to keep it white or
not? It's a simple yes no answer, isn't
it?
>> Yes, I do. But like I said a moment ago,
I would be happy and most people on my
side of the fence would be happy if we
rolled back the clock so that Britain is
still demographically
>> so that you want black people to go back
to Africa then. Is it
>> I want black criminals to be deported.
And
>> what about the noncriminals? What about
because you just said you want to keep
>> like I said, right? Look, let let me
just like I said, we would roll back the
tape. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> So people who arrived three years ago
would go first. people arrived 60 years
ago would go last.
>> So the England football team for
example, half of them should go back to
Caribbean.
>> Well, how would you feel as an as
someone I imagine you've got loyalty?
>> You're not answering this question.
>> If the Egyptian football team was from
Saka,
>> should she remove Saka? Should we send
him back to Nigeria or wherever he's
from?
>> Yeah, absolutely. 100%.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
The first person I would deport it was
the first two people, Muhammad, would be
you and Ali Dawa and anyone you're
connected to, you'd all be deported. So,
but like I said, I I said I'll give you
five 10 minutes for this to talk about
the fight. We've had a really good
evening. We've had a good discussion. If
you want to if you want to schedule a
debate, I'm all for it. Let's talk about
it via email. Let's get the fight
organized. Let's agree to everything,
okay? Let's get it done. But I've sworn
in the Bible. Okay. You can put this up
on all your social media channels. The
fight's happening.
>> You also attack You also attack Islam
quite a lot. Do you What are the five
pillars of Islam?
>> Oh,
so obviously I don't I don't recite this
every day and I'm quite frankly I'm not
really interested, Muhammad. But as you
[laughter] know,
>> you know, you've got an attack on
religion that you don't know the five
pillars of. Look,
>> I've written a book about Islam as you
Well, yeah, but you don't know the five
pillars, do you?
>> Well, look, you're trying to you're
trying to catch me out here. I I will
admit.
>> How could you write a book about
religion? Five pillars. Paul,
>> okay, I will admit that you are a very
learned person when it comes to
religion. I've watched your debates.
Okay, I respect all of that.
>> You've got your views, I've got my
views,
>> and I'm just looking forward to getting
in the ring with you. Okay, and like I
say, it's going to be fireworks. And I
think everyone on your side of the
fence, everyone on my side of the fence
cannot wait for it to happen. We've
agreed the broad brushstrokes and I'm
sure we'll, you know, get get all the
small print sorted out. We'll get a
poster. We'll get a promotional video.
We'll blast it everywhere and we'll make
it happen. Okay.
>> But I do have to go cuz I did say I need
to go within 10 minutes and I've given
you
>> I'll let you go, Paul. I mean, it's uh
it's been a pleasure talking to you in a
in a weird kind of way. Um I I hope that
you've we've both uh understood each
other's worldview a little bit more.
Maybe in the future we'll have another
discussion where we speak exclusively
about Islam because I feel like I feel
honestly genuinely I feel like if you
understand it uh you'll change your
views on it. Um and I think that
>> I would strongly disagree with with all
respect I would strongly disagree. Like
I said I've I've written a book on
Islam. If you give me an address I'll
send you a copy so you can you can maybe
fact check it. Yeah.
>> Yeah. You can send me a book. I'll fact
check it. I'll send you some resources
as well if you're interested.
>> Okay. And then we can uh we can discuss
it later on.
>> Yeah. And as well as jumping in the
cage, I'm sure we can have a debate in
the future.
>> Sure.
>> But I'm sure it's not it's not going to
be civilized when we jump into the cage.
I think we both agree on that.
>> Well, whatever. I mean, that's the last
question I wanted to ask actually
because about the fight. If so, the
referee's going to stop it if if you
know if you're in a in a in a troubled
position.
>> Is that is the referee is the one who's
going to
>> If I'm in a troubled position.
[laughter]
>> Okay.
>> Well, I don't want to be done as you
said for ABA.
>> All right. Yeah. We use our example.
Yes. I mean, just the look the rules of
MMA apply. So, you've got submission
win, you've got KO, you've got TKO. Um,
>> if you say I quit like loudly enough, is
that
>> Yeah, of course. Yeah. if I tap out or
you tap out or I say I quit, you say you
quit, which is more likely in my
opinion. But yeah, [laughter]
it's the rules of an MMA fight. That's
how it's going to go down.
>> All right, my friend. We'll see whatever
we [laughter]
see you later, Paul. Take care.
>> Okay, see you later. Bye-bye.
>> Hey, you are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.